[Music]
let me just tell you that Eric is a
professor of sociology is the director
of the Institute for public knowledge at
NYU right now he is the author of books
including modern romance with Aziz
Ansari which I don't think he's going to
talk about tonight but maybe in Q&A we
can if you have need advice on that but
and the heat wave a social autopsy of
disaster in Chicago which we have on
sale tonight and he'll be sticking
around afterwards of course to sign it
as well so we're honored to have Eric
here to talk tonight about climate
change and the future of cities join me
in giving him a big round of applause hi
there can you hear me okay yeah I hear
myself now well thank you so much for
coming out tonight I was really worried
that people weren't gonna come and then
I told them to advertise me as the guy
with the underwater drone but I don't
have an underwater drone at all the I
then had it came up with another
strategy which is that once I wrote this
book with diseases Ansari I realized
that if we tease that people would
sometimes come thinking Aziz which is
going to show up like in San Francisco
you know you can relate like the idea is
like you're gonna go to this folk band
and Jerry Garcia is gonna be there
because he always plays with his folk
band so I just want to welcome Aziz
Ansari from no no actually he's not
coming at all I'm so he's not would
never even consider coming to do this
with me so I'm pretty much on my own
talking about climate change with no
technological device other than the
clicker but let me get my face off of
there I think we have a lot of stuff to
talk about and it will probably be a
little bit less jolly than
evening with disease but maybe we'll do
that another time climate change and the
future of cities can anybody tell me
where and when this shot was taken sandy
or Katrina Russian River yeah you said
it there too but you said it so quickly
that it wasn't it was gonna ruin the
whole you know thing so so that was
steps San Jose two weeks ago and and no
one was talking storm of the century
right that was a rainstorm in San Jose
so I just I don't have that much more to
say about this right now but I want a
you know we're gonna what we're going to
talk about today is the convergence of
these two trends that you hear a lot
about rarely in unison right one is
urbanization and the others climate
change I want to talk about the
significance and this is long now and
we're going to be kind of emphasizing
more of the now than the long for a lot
of it but I'm gonna start talking
towards the end about the long part
because what I want to try to persuade
you tonight is that we have some
incredibly consequential decisions we're
going to make in the next few years
about how we build the places that that
we inhabit including this place and when
you hear a political leader talk about
an infrastructure investment I want you
to start thinking about the
infrastructures that we use in our
day-to-day life and when they were built
and how long they last and then I want
you to project forward what it will mean
to build infrastructure for this coming
period of time okay so that that's we're
gonna get to the long questions I'm a
social scientist I'm here this year
because I'm at the Center for Advanced
Study and behavioral sciences at
Stanford and so this chart that you see
here which I presume everybody in the
room is familiar with is actually a very
strange chart to start a social science
talk with and I often have to explain it
to my colleagues in social science you
know many of the social sciences were
built on this idea that there's
something social that explain
the world we live in and because there's
a social explanation there's precisely
not a natural explanation so the you
know economics and political science and
sociology they were built in some ways
in opposition to studies of nature which
means when you see a chart that shows
you know the concentration of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere and global
temperatures and you see that incredible
spike people sometimes call this the
hockey stick graph it actually needs
explanation in some quarters it doesn't
need explanation here nor do I need to
persuade you of why you should be
concerned about this the point is those
two things are going up together and you
know one of the reasons that there's
this kind of group of us who has tried
to make the case that this is an urgent
matter is because when we think about
greenhouse gas emissions when we think
about our our sources of energy are the
ways we consume things the conversation
that we're having in policy terms is
about whether in the next 20 or 40 or 50
or 100 years we're going to be following
the red line up above which gets us to a
level of heating that would really be
catastrophic or whether we're getting
beyond the blue line which would just be
really [ __ ] terrifying but not
totally catastrophic we have serious
stuff that we're going to be managing
and and and that's what I want you know
want us to start focusing on the issue
is that the you know the real danger we
have right now is that we have to start
this this project of mitigating of
reducing our consumption of greenhouse
gases but the problem is that if this
clicker that I'm holding in my hands
suddenly got converted into a magic
button and right the second by pressing
the forward slide in addition to getting
you to the next image I also could stop
all global greenhouse gas emissions that
would be an awesome technology that that
you would be feel very proud to have
witnessed up there with the underwater
drone but as awesome as it would be to
do that it actually wouldn't do much to
stop rising temperatures or sea levels
for the next century or so because we
have
baked so much carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere already that no matter what
we do we can't just mitigate we have to
mitigate but but we have to do more that
wasn't there in the practice round let's
not worry about it right now we're
already at a moment where we're seeing a
spike in extreme weather events that are
consequential that that kill many people
that force waves of migration we're
seeing this all over the world this is
just a couple year period that happened
to be two of the hottest years in
history then 2016 came around and was
even hotter so we're seeing a rising
incidence of droughts and heat waves and
hurricanes and things that we have to
worry about we're beginning to see
serious displacement and migration and
emerging conflicts that are related to
the spike in extreme weather and you
should know that our last president
before he left office issued a
memorandum in which he he made it clear
what the implications for US national
security were from climate change this
is not something that the president was
out on a limb doing the Pentagon has
been sounding the same note that think
of climate change is a threat multiplier
and and that continues to be the case
that that climate change is a factor
that that that increases the the
possibility of the probability of
dangerous conflicts in many places
around the world so it's a it's a
serious thing at the global level and
probably many of you here tonight know
that climate change also is a local
concern not just because of the image of
San Jose but these are the walls that
keep much of San Francisco dry this is
around the Embarcadero so you know not
too far from here and we don't get to
see what that looks like very often but
that's what our walls in this city look
like today we all know about the Orval
Dam now none of us knew about the Orval
dam a few weeks ago but that's one of
the things that's going to start to
happen with more frequency is that
systems and structures that held
everything together that we took for
granted will suddenly flash up as being
vulnerable and we will have to deal with
them in some cases we'll have to deal
with them in very urgent ways
sometimes they'll have the luxury of
time but not that much time what I'm
saying right now is that we are about to
enter a process that people who think
about the climate a lot call either
adaptation or transformation we're gonna
have to change the way we live and we're
gonna have to change the places that we
live adaptation is kind of a soft and
fuzzy word it may it sounds kind of
innocent you know we're just going to
kind of gradually shift the way we do
things and build things to live in this
new world of extremes transformation is
probably more accurate for what we're
going to have to do and I hope I can
persuade you of that soon and so what
what I mostly want to talk to you about
tonight is what it will mean to adapt or
transform cities and the way that I want
to do that is I want to begin with this
note of caution and that is when we
think about investing in structures and
infrastructures and we think about
building and rebuilding cities we're
talking about spending real resources it
is extraordinarily expensive to build
new subway systems and new seawalls
new kinds of high-rise buildings new
flood management systems it is
extraordinarily expensive and so as a
preliminary let me tell you that as we
enter into this conversation you should
know that that one of the great dangers
of dealing with climate change through
adaptation projects is that it will
inevitably increase the problem of
environmental justice the problem of
environmental injustice to a level that
I think we haven't really taken
seriously yet
and when you read about international
diplomacy around climate and you hear
about negotiations between the wealthier
countries in the world and the poorer
countries in the world there's issues
about mitigation who's going to reduce
consumption of greenhouse gases but
there's also this conversation about a
fund where wealthier countries will put
in money to help poorer countries in the
world adapt and that's generally what's
the most vulnerable in these changes of
the negotiation of negotiate
negotiation so I want you to bear in
mind as we go through this thing you're
gonna see a lot of expensive ideas and
any time you see an expensive idea know
that implementing it is going to be
exacerbating inequality issues okay off
we go
so I have a crew with me from Chicago
tonight
I've invited some old friends who I grew
up with who come to the Bay Area and so
what I wanted to do because I grew up in
Chicago and Chicago is a place where we
actually got some early warning signs
about the possible dangers of living in
a hotter world and so to introduce you
to the way that I think about this issue
I want to bring you back to Chicago in
1995 so Chicago gets hot in the summer
but this is a summer where it was
unusually hot the temperature in July
hit about 106 degrees and the heat index
which is like the windchill these are
really foreign concepts to people who
live in the Bay Area where the weather
is always perfect I know but but the
heat index which tells you what a
typical person feels hit about a hundred
and twenty six and and cities in San
Francisco people start saying oh like
that eight once you get above like 75
people start freaking out God how do
they live but the thing about Chicago is
that Chicago like like most urban areas
is what's called the heat island cities
are heat islands because all of the the
concrete the pavement the building's
they attract the Sun and all of that
pollution that we put out from cars and
from industry traps the heat and why
that's significant is that at night when
the outlying areas cooled down city air
traps the heat and it tends to be
significantly warmer so you don't get
the natural cooling that can keep people
alive and Chicago the the nights were
also very very hot so it happened in
1995 is that the city set its record for
energy consumption that's now become
pretty mundane anytime it's hot cities
set their records for energy consumption
it used to be the case that one of the
things that kind of helped us understand
and appreciate being American and living
in a place like this is that we could
rely on our energy working on our
you're working when we really needed it
I think now in many cities we just
expect that the infrastructure and the
power is going to break down
it certainly is what happened in Chicago
these are emergency workers I just stole
this image from a television station in
Chicago which is why the image is so bad
so bear with me and please don't sue me
if you're watching this ABC but these
are guys trying to spray down a
substation guess guess what didn't work
about 250,000 households in Chicago lost
access to power when it felt like it was
126 and as you know if you live in a
city when you don't have power if you
live in a high-rise building you can't
pump water up to high floors the
elevators don't go up and down the power
you know the lights are out obviously
it's very dangerous for older people and
frail people in particular about 3,000
hydrants in Chicago were opened at the
same time this is before they had the
spray that could you know release a
small amount of water and so many
hydrants were open at the same time that
entire neighborhoods lost water pressure
in addition to high rises again 126
degrees the transit system in Chicago
broke down the plates on the bridges
were expanding so the bridges couldn't
open and close the rails on train lines
were moving just enough that it was very
dangerous for the trains to travel
quickly when the power was out you
couldn't get the traffic lights working
so you had gridlock in Chicago which is
significant because thousands of people
needed emergency care because they were
overheating in their homes in fact so
many people in Chicago needed to get
emergency care from ambulances that half
of the hospitals in Chicago had to go on
bypass status which means that they
closed their doors and refused to take
in any more emergency patients because
they literally could not handle the load
and the problem in Chicago in 1995 is
that there was no centralized system for
figuring out which hospitals were open
and which hospitals were closed so the
ambulance would go to a place and knock
on the door and be told that they
couldn't come in and they'd have to
drive to another nearby hospital the
odds of which it was also closed and
remember they're driving through
gridlocked traffic so you have this
incredible backup of the
violence's in a situation where people
need urgent care to prevent the heat
related illness from turning into
something truly deadly but that didn't
work so the reason I wound up writing
this book about the heatwave is that
more than 700 people died from a heat
event that lasted just about two and a
half to three days thousands more were
hospitalized and this is truly an
amazing event what puzzled me when I
first learned about it I was actually I
just moved to Berkeley I come to
Berkeley to do a PhD in sociology and I
started reading about this event and it
was it was a strange thing to learn
about scientifically because we actually
have pretty sophisticated climate models
that predict how much mortality and how
much morbidity you would get under
different conditions and will end and
the kind of climate health world was
really freaked out about this event
because they kept saying this was so
much worse than our models tell us it
should be something else must be going
on but what was it and they kind of
released this you know report published
in the American Journal of Public Health
saying you know we don't know what's
going on so I started doing what i call
it came to call a social autopsy kind of
like opening up the skin of the city in
the same way that a medical examiner
opens up the skin when they're gonna do
a physical autopsy to try to figure out
kind of what what broke down and what
made the event so deadly and there are a
lot of things that that I do in the book
that I won't tell you about but one
thing I want to mention you know quickly
because it's going to be central to our
discussion here is I was really
interested in this question about why
some places in Chicago were so much more
vulnerable than other places and and
what could I learn about what happened
in the heatwave from looking at this and
so the first thing you do when you're a
sociologist is you map stuff especially
when you're working in a city and if you
know anything about the city of Chicago
you'll see that the red areas on this
map are important because those are what
the neighborhoods are in what's called
the black belt the historically
african-american neighborhoods in
Chicago on the south side and the west
side they are disproportionately poor
Chicago is almost perfectly segregated
so they're almost entirely
african-american in many places and this
is the kind of map that is completely
predictable like
if you if you if a disaster is coming to
a big city you expect to see a map like
this so that was important to discover
but it wasn't scientifically interesting
to find a pattern like that
so what I then did is I tried to flip
that map and look at a different
question which was could I understand
which neighborhoods in Chicago proved to
be the most resilient which were the
places that actually had the lowest
death rates and no one had asked that
question but it turned out to be really
fascinating because it was it was a very
mixed set of neighborhoods and part of
what was interesting is that three of
the neighborhoods that had incredibly
low death rates should have been in the
red they're entirely african-american
perfectly segregated disproportionately
poor a lot of vulnerable people and it
kind of didn't make sense on paper that
you would have such high survival rates
in places that should have been so
vulnerable so I want to look closer and
I went back to Chicago I went back home
and I started looking very closely at
which neighborhoods had done well and
which hadn't done well and it was
especially attuned to neighborhoods that
were right next to each other pairs of
neighborhoods that looked statistically
very similar but that had very different
experiences in the event so this is a
neighborhood on the south side of the
city called Englewood which is
characteristic of a certain kind of
Chicago area that had been massively
depopulated and the decades leading up
to 1995 less than half of the population
from 1950 was there it had a lot of
abandoned Lots a lot of empty buildings
a lot of tall grass a depleted
commercial infrastructure and it's
possible to look at this and think like
oh that's a green neighborhood but
that's not a healthy green neighborhood
that's a green environment that actually
discourages people from going out of
their homes and into public life
especially older people who'd be more
likely to be alone and frail there's not
much to do in a neighborhood like this
unless you're dealing drugs in which
case that ecology is great for you
because if the cops come you just drop
your stuff in the grass and run and
that's basically how people treated
these neighborhoods that's a
neighborhood across the street from
angle wood which on paper looks almost
identical it's called auburn gresham
entirely african-american very poor
what's so striking about our regression
is that they didn't have that loss of
population the residential
infrastructure was very similar to what
it was 30 or 40 years before the
neighborhood organizational structure
very similar the commercial
infrastructure relatively robust more
like a poor neighborhood you find in in
New York City than in a neighborhood
like like Englewood from before and what
I discovered is that the death rate in
the first neighborhood you saw Englewood
was ten times higher than the death rate
in auburn gresham and moreover the life
expectancy in Englewood this
neighborhood the life expectancy from
living here is five years lower than the
life expectancy of living across the
streets and I came to believe that there
was something that that social
scientists had failed to appreciate
about what organizes the world we live
in and I came to call it social
infrastructure the the network the set
of places and institutions that shape
the way we interact with each other when
it works well it can help people connect
in a daily way so you get longer life
expectancy you get a stronger sense of
cohesion and connection and community
and when it doesn't work well it
actually promotes very unhealthy ways of
living the kind of living where you stay
inside you it engenders distrust it
makes you more isolated and and less
likely to survive an extreme event so as
it happens you know this kind of insight
was missing in the public conversation
about the heat wave of 1995 could I just
ask really quickly could you raise your
hand high if you have strong memories of
the Great Chicago heat wave of 1995 I
want everyone to look around the room at
the moment because it's really telling
you know first of all that my friends
from Chicago
are either very shy people or they don't
remember it either which is doubly
embarrassing as I realize it now because
I think I've sent a book to each one of
them already but but anyway we don't
know about this event it was a non-event
despite the fact that it really is one
of the great disasters but one of the
reasons it's a non-event is because the
city of Chicago really treated this as a
public relations crisis even more than
as a public hell
hazard and one reason I know this is
because this is the the city never held
public hearings about what happened this
is the only major report published by
the city it was a mayor's commission
could I just ask does anybody see
anything funny about this report cover
there's a snowflake on the cover which
is a very odd thing for a report about
why 700 people died in a heatwave anyone
see something that's missing like you
would expect it to be there and it isn't
it's a how about a word a concept
disasters would be a good one anything
else more specific in that genre
how about heatwave thank you very much
so this is a report about why so many
people died in a heatwave from a city
that refused to hold public hearings and
it's got a snowflake and it doesn't have
the concept heatwave you should have
that too it should that but this is a
report that was designed to hide rather
than to show right this was a
publication meant to disappear something
which is a heart it's the kind of thing
we associate with like Central America
but I want to I want to argue that this
is kind of how it's a very nice metaphor
for how we manage climate issues for a
long time in this country and that sense
is part of a genre my book came out in
2002 it was a really exciting moment for
me you know it was on fresh air and
Malcolm Gladwell wrote an article about
it and I did all this media and I felt
like I am now a social scientist who's
changing the world and people will
understand this issue in a way they
never would have before I'm gonna make a
difference with my pen and then in 2003
there was a heat wave in Europe and
70,000 people more than 70,000 people
died and not a single European political
official paid a major price for it
because they - a person said nothing
like this has ever happened before how
could we have known this a heat wave
could be so deadly so I was totally
crushed it was you know made me think I
had to work a lot harder and we all have
to work harder actually it turns out we
all have to work harder on these issues
because it's very hard to convey a sense
of their seriousness in the urgency what
I do know is if we what I learned from
that Chicago story and from the European
story is that
we're facing these incredible threats
and I'll tell you something else but
just to go back to this for a second
well it's especially scary for me about
the European heat wave story is that we
know it mostly as a French story because
the French were very open about the fact
that so many people were dying
so was covered as a French heat wave was
only later when we looked at the
epidemiological data that we learned
that in fact there were tens of
thousands of deaths across Europe but
here's what's haunting for me the the
heat wave in Europe lasted about three
weeks and France has about sixty million
people and there did in 2003 when I
learned what I looked at the numbers is
that the death rate in France from a
heat wave that lasted three weeks was
basically the same as the death rate in
Chicago for a heat wave that lasted two
and a half or three days and it raises
for me this question of you know what
would happen to Chicago or Milwaukee or
Philadelphia or Washington or New York
or Phoenix or Los Angeles or even San
Francisco if a heat wave like the one
that hit Europe in 2003 just happened to
hit here and those are the kinds of
things that we now have to be thinking
about okay so then I moved to New York
and does anybody recognize this that's
sandy right there there's sandy not San
Jose that's actually sandy about $1,000
wow that was San Jose it would be really
weird about a thousand miles wide
actually when sandy hit New York was a
combination of several storms but you
know when sandy hit New York it was not
a hurricane my friends in New York talk
about having dodged a bullet but I want
to show you what it means what it looks
like to dodge a bullet
okay so it's hard to picture a heat wave
you close your eyes and try to think
about what a heat wave looks like and
you probably draw a blank or you see
kids playing and a fire hydrant or
something but you have an image of Sandy
I bet because there's an iconic
iconography for it and this is the great
image right this is this lower Manhattan
out of power and I live in the zone that
had no power
and I had a 92 year old father-in-law at
the time who was in a wheelchair who
lived on the 10th floor of a building
that was across the street from where
the power was on but he did not have
power and this was a stunning thing that
happened the wave of water that came
into the East Side of Manhattan was
about 14 and a half feet high and the
wall at the substation on the Lower East
Side on 14th Street was about 14 feet
high and the equipment was on the ground
level it wasn't elevated and so as soon
as the water breached that wall it was
out and what was amazing to me any of
you guys spend time in New York and you
raise your hand if you spend time in New
York
okay so anyone ever lived in New York
City okay
New Yorkers back me up if you think I'm
right about this but so I've lived in
Manhattan for about 15 years and the
world view when you live in Manhattan is
like okay some terrible shit's gonna
happen but if there's ever a situation
where there was no power they would find
a way to keep it on where we live and
they like shut it off in the Bronx or
something like that right I mean I'm not
saying that with pride or anything I
don't feel good about that but you you
know there's this feeling when you live
in San Francisco and you're like you
know you live in a great like a super
star city and the feeling you have is
like they're gonna take care of us in
our neighborhood because we're the
awesome people and and I think a lot of
people in New York really felt that way
right week you know come on we're in a
bar you could admit it you know like
it's that sense like I you know I'm
probably half of you have a house in New
Zealand or something like everybody's
got a way of getting of getting out so
that was the thing is you were down
there and you there was no getting out
you were just in the dark and the power
wasn't coming on and you talked to
people and say you know when is the
power coming on and they would say the
power is coming on maybe next week and
you would say there must be some kind of
mistake but there wasn't a mistake
except for in the way that we built
things it turns out that Manhattan is
wasn't the only place that lost power
this is Long Island about 8 million
households in the country lost power
more than a million people along Island
as well and in Long Island as in many
American communities there's a
technology that we use to sustain the
power grid it's called the pole you
probably are familiar with the pole
we have these electrical wires and we
put them on top of poles and you know we
keep right on top of the electrical
wires trees yes you guys are sharp and
and and what happens routinely on a
windy day not even a super storm but the
trees go down and they fall I mean no
it's not surprising when the power grid
goes down so we know that the Long
Island Power Authority had a board
meeting a few days before sandy hit it
was a long scheduled board meeting sandy
was on its way we knew it was coming but
they had other things to discuss so they
talked for according to the minutes of
the meeting I think it's either 37 or 57
seconds about pre sandy planning things
like pruning the trees to make sure that
that they don't go down but they you
know so if you don't think about these
things a long time in advance you have
problems but even if you don't think
about things in the short time advanced
you can compound them the subway flooded
like a bathtub and what's truly strange
about this image is look closely New
Yorkers its 86th Street which was
completely dry and so this is a
horrifying image because it shows you
like we built a lot of stuff underground
without thinking about the possibility
of flooding and it's very hard to keep
water from going underground because
it's not just entering into the stations
it goes through all the grids like when
when you walk in New York or Chicago or
I don't know the BART system well enough
to know how the how the circulation
system works but you know if their grids
on the ground the water goes right under
them so this is scary but here's a cool
story about New York City the city and
the state were actually very concerned
about climate change and they were
concerned about hurricanes and extreme
weather events now you don't need to be
concerned about climate change to be
concerned about extreme weather but
there tends to be a strong relationship
between them it may be very interesting
in this with the current president we
have to see whether they're interested
in sparing us from storms even though
they don't believe in climate change I
guess the early science is like getting
rid of all the weather generating data
and technology to tell us we probably
shouldn't be optimistic on that front
but New York was really concerned about
it so here's what they did before sandy
hit they evacuated the cars from
subway system and move them to higher
ground they went in underground and they
pulled out as many of the electrical
wires that they could so that when the
salt water came into the system
it wouldn't corrode the lines all that
much and the water came in as predicted
they got it right away they pumped it
out they replaced the lines in about
five days much of the system was up and
running again
okay and every day that the New York
City subway system is down there's X
billion dollars of economic damage okay
it's an expensive thing to get wrong now
across the river anyone here from Jersey
yeah there's like 20 times more people
that from Jersey here but nobody's
admitting it so so it's just because
what happened is that half the people
who said they were from Manhattan
actually grew up in like t-mac and they
just don't want to say it so now they've
already raised their hand is Manhattan
and they're embarrassed but okay so
here's what happens in New Jersey the
governor doesn't believe much in climate
change he's not inclined to think it's a
serious thing he doesn't do a lot of
work prepping the city the cities around
the New Jersey or the state to deal with
an emerging crisis and so as sandy
approaches the New Jersey Transit leaves
it's cars right next to the river and
they have a hundred and ten million
dollars of flooding destroying the cars
which means not only that the taxpayers
of New Jersey and ladies and gentlemen
all of us in this room wind up paying
for the new cars but also it takes much
longer for New Jersey to bounce back and
get the commute right again
so everybody suffers from that situation
right you didn't even have to order the
bridge closed the the transit system
went down right so that's a so that's a
story about what what can you do if you
take seriously climate threats before
they happen right there's not not the
big story about mitigation but just
little things that you might not think
about that actually like it makes a
difference what the leadership is okay
but don't let me get carried away with
the idea that New York did everything
right because this is a billion dollar
subway station that went up at the
bottom of the battery about a year
before sandy hits
and guess what did not survive sandy
those are my colleagues at NYU as it
happens the health infrastructure for
much of Manhattan is built along the
East River several hospitals are
clustered together there it turns out
that they're also completely vulnerable
to floodwaters and we learned that the
hard way in Sandy so the regulation was
that you had to have your generators
your backup generators on the roof but
you couldn't have your fuel exposed so
you put your fuel in the basement where
people wouldn't be able to breathe it in
so when the floodwaters came in to the
basement they mixed with the fuel and
destroyed the computer systems and tens
of thousands of laboratory animals who
are there for medical testing and this
hospitals were really in trouble and
this is I love this image this is a
scene from the neonatal NICU at NYU
hospital so they they managed to in a
situation where there was no power in
the hospital they carried these
premature babies down eight flights of
stairs pumping air into their lungs with
paper bags remove them out into a
hurricane into an ambulance which went
through flooded streets to go uptown and
not a single child died which is amazing
right and and the moral of the story is
that if we screw up the planning in
advance we need heroes to get us out of
these situations and sometimes we have
them and often we don't so how do we
start to think about climate security
for a world that's getting hotter how do
how do we begin to put this on the
agenda of the kinds of things that
cities need to think about really
regardless of who the president is
there's some places on earth that won't
work if you don't have a wall you need
some kind of gate to keep the water out
because the cities just are too low and
the water is already too high so if
you've been to Venice you know that
Venice is building the system they
called Moses a series of sea gates
that's going up because Venice is going
under this is London
which would be a lot wetter wear it not
for this hard system and after Sandy
happens many people suggested that New
York City build this it's very funny so
this is an amazing thing Auto but it
turns out that Auto like everybody else
forgot about Staten Island which is like
right over here toward Staten Island
gets no respect so this is Staten Island
here
that's the Verrazano Bridge and people
said we need to build a giant gate to
protect the protect you know lower
Manhattan where the money is
where the infrastructure is where the
people where the people are now this is
how disaster planning works it's like
triads you know what can you save whose
and this is going to get very serious
because we're going to start to be
thinking we're going to start thinking
about what are the places that we're
going to protect who are the people
we're going to protect how are we gonna
make those decisions it's gonna get very
interesting for us in our lifetimes
hopefully so so people said well
building this gate here but the thing
about the gate is it's got a lot of
Appeal and it's also got a lot of
problems the appeal is problem solved
right we don't have to worry about the
storm coming in because we've got these
gates around the city well the bad news
is first of all you can't wall in the
entire United States and you can't wall
in the entire world so you're gonna have
to make some choices as it happens when
the water smashes into that gate and the
sediment splashes into that gate it
doesn't just powder eyes it goes to
Staten Island and it goes to Brooklyn
and Queens in Connecticut and I don't
know about San Francisco but New York is
a pretty litigious place and when you
have sediment and water that is now
threatening the viability of other dense
settlements they tend to sue and so you
can't put a thing up without you know
real struggle okay
there's another problem which is it's
incredibly expensive and another problem
which is how high are you going to build
it if you start to take into
consideration various scenarios of sea
level rise plus the storm surge that
comes on top of it you can find yourself
building walls so that we're standing
here but we don't see much of Marin
and I don't know that we want to do that
in San Francisco another thing is the
walls like that we that we make these
sea gates are open most of the time so
the water flows in and out the notion is
you just close them when there's extreme
weather but if we start to get serious
sea level rise and more and more extreme
weather we're talking about keeping
those gates closed and it turns out
there's an entire ecosystem that lies
behind there right the Hudson River the
East River and you do real damage if you
just build a wall take that however you
want so so that's a strategy for dealing
with climate change that people talk
about is kind of armoring defending
that's one of the things that we can do
in the face of the weather that's coming
is we can armor try to keep the water
out try to keep the heat out another
thing that we can do and this is very
tricky as we can retreat so say like you
know what we should never have settled
here in the first place this is a very
dangerous place to build let's start to
move people and move structures to
different areas here's a long view
problem there's about 800 million people
in the world who live in coastal or
Delta cities that are less than ten feet
above sea water sea sea level and as we
get sea level rise and as we see an
incidence of emerging weather increase
we'll have to face these really tough
questions about what's going to happen
to these 800 million plus people and the
very expensive structures and
infrastructures that make their lives
possible and that is not going to be an
easy thing to manage let me tell you
that is going to be a very serious
problem that our generation or future
generations has to deal with so normally
we think about retreat from places like
the Marshall Islands or the Maldives
but after sandy a group of beachfront
communities in Staten Island lobbied the
state for hundreds of millions of
dollars to be bought out of their homes
to relocate to higher ground as an
incredible thing right because these are
this Staten Island so this is a white
you know working-class and middle-class
community that tends to vote Republican
and not believe that climate change
is real and also outside of fire and
police they don't think the government
can do that much to help and now they're
working with government to try to help
them get through climate change so it's
an amazing thing but it's a haunting
thing also because they got the money
they were able to pull it through but
where do you say no as soon as those
three neighborhoods got money a bunch of
other neighborhood said we want it to
and then Bloomberg came in and said whoa
whoa whoa we can't be buying people out
here because think about all the New
Yorkers who who would want this so we
should build more expensive structures
and just build like high-tech places on
the water but then you give the beach to
very wealthy people and people don't
want to sell their houses or walk away
from their houses on the beach to turn
it over to the next wave of real estate
developers so that's a tough area this
is not like a long-term thing solely the
state of Louisiana issued this map you
might not think of the state of
Louisiana as a leader when it comes to
climate change warning but look at all
these areas in red that are projected to
be underwater in the next 50 years you
know that's our problem no matter their
you know no matter who they vote for red
or blue they've got a situation and
similarly the highlighted areas are
places in the United States that
continually reapply for disaster relief
funding and at some point you say
actually maybe it doesn't make sense to
rebuild there but go tell that to people
in New Orleans it's tricky so a third
strategy is to accommodate to kind of
let the water let the water in
let the climate come let's find a way to
live with water in some cases this can
be very useful there's places on earth
like Singapore the Netherlands
California that actually could use the
water so when it rains and there's
flooding you know rather than just
building a park you build a park that
can convert as this one can
into a water storage basin that then
diverts the water underground where it
can be recycled or reused for a number
of different purposes in Singapore it's
a matter of life and death there's just
not enough water it's not coming and in
California could be too so there are a
lot of places that are trying to figure
out you know what are ways that we can
live with the the water that's coming
the heat that's coming those are very
tough questions I'd love to talk about
that as well there's some places on
earth like the Rockaway Peninsula which
you can see here otto got that one right
where it's very hard to just accommodate
it and let the water in because it's
incredibly vulnerable that's the kind of
thing that we used to call a barrier
island right but it turns out we we we
built on all of our barrier islands we
settled them and the government actually
subsidized settlement of those areas
right the government built
infrastructure the government built
housing the government subsidized flood
insurance right so we we had a strategic
policy of doing it
the Rockaways by the way are gorgeous if
you've never been out there it's a
beautiful place like you kind of can't
believe you're on the beach we've got
this gorgeous boardwalk that's what the
boardwalk look like after sandy that's
what happens to barrier island when
storm hits and and when I went out to do
reporting for a story I did for The New
Yorker right after sandy I discovered
you know that remarkably as in Chicago
where social infrastructure really
mattered in the neighborhoods of New
York City when the systems and the
infrastructures broke down as they
inevitably do the social infrastructure
really became crucial so here is a surf
club where people really knew the
neighborhood well and knew their
neighbors well and had a terrific
Network and we're managed to convert
their facility from a place where people
went to surf on the weekends to a place
that served more than 10,000 people in
the Rockaways got them connected to
plumbers and electricians and got them
food and got them cleaning supplies and
help them get their pharmaceuticals and
did an extraordinary amount of work this
is a youth employment agency and a kind
of a youth support agency in Red Hook
it's called the Red Hook initiative
which also completely converted into a
neighborhood Relief Center
and what I learned is I I looked through
different neighborhoods and you
and that was subsequently confirmed by
more quantitative research is that the
neighborhoods that had very strong
social infrastructure and strong social
capital fared better in Sandy and also
recovered more quickly than places where
the levels of social capital were lower
and people had higher levels of
estrangement and so as we think about
the climate I want to emphasize that we
shouldn't just be thinking about these
big structures that we build we should
also be thinking about the social
structures that organize our lives
that's true for disasters and it's true
every day I want to wrap up and make
sure we have time for conversation and
the way I'm gonna do it is I'm gonna
spend a few minutes talking to you about
a remarkable thing that happened in New
York and that happened to me and my work
life after sandy it happened that at the
time there was a big a very bitter fight
in Congress about whether to provide
emergency funds to the region that was
affected by Sandy you probably are
familiar with these political debates
where people get very ideological about
who's responsible and who should pay but
after a fight Congress appropriated
about 50 billion dollars to the region
affected by Sandy for for relief and the
president obama had a commission that
that was working on the sandy project he
appointed Shaun Donovan the HUD
secretary to head this commission and
they pulled aside a couple billion
dollars for a project they called
rebuild by design which was meant to
generate ideas and also funding for
innovative infrastructure projects for
the region they said basically after
sandy what we typically do when there's
a disaster in this country is we say
we're gonna build it back we're gonna
build back what we lost but that doesn't
make sense anymore right we no longer
have the luxury of just building back
what we had before actually we have
federal regulations that required cities
and states to build back exactly what
was there before and nothing better so
the policy had to be changed but now the
idea was we're gonna set aside a couple
of billion dollars we're gonna have this
international design competition and
we're going to generate exciting ways to
think about infrastructure projects and
they I had written this article about
sandy and the White House had read it
and we've done a bunch of public
my Institute and they came to me and
said you know we'd like you to be the
research director for this event and we
want to have you do it at your Institute
in New York so we said sure even though
we really had no idea we were doing at
first we kind of built the airplane
while we were flying it and it was an
amazing thing because we had these
design teams of engineers and architects
and landscape architects and climate
scientists and social scientists and my
job for three months was to show them
around the region and to identify needs
and possibilities vulnerabilities things
that we could do together and this is a
scene from a day we spent on Red Hook
there's a 3-month research process that
all the teams had to go through that
came to the project without a plan they
just came as a team that was selected
for their excellence and achievement
about 150 teams applied we picked ten
finalists three months of research they
did three months of civic participation
talking to different stakeholders from
community organizations and residents of
public housing buildings to mayors and
governors and small business owners so
really you know not just coming into
communities and saying here's what you
need but listening then selecting sites
and spending three months designing
things and the way I want to wrap up is
by just showing you the ideas for one of
the winning projects that came out of
this which has a really dramatic idea
for how we would do New York differently
you remember this image right New York
without power
lower Manhattan without power and these
one team from Bianca Ingalls who's a
very prominent young Danish architect in
his group called the big group was you
know we want to make sure that New York
looks like this next time there's a
storm this is like sandy right how do we
how do we make New York look like this
and so they came for the project that
they called for a while the big you and
if you look at that kind of yellow
illuminated line around here think of
that as you know like a curse of you
from a third grader learning cursive
that the idea was to build something
like a protective wall around around
lower Manhattan but not exactly what you
think of when you think of a wall and it
really needed it I told you you know
I've emphasized that inequality is an
issue
around climate change adaptation some
people are more exposed than others but
but we're all exposed in some ways like
we all affected by water we all have to
breathe so it's not like you can opt out
of climate change and this is a building
a very expensive building in Tribeca I
have good friends who live you know next
door to this it flooded the garage
attendant who was trying to save the
cars of the clients died because the
water came in so quickly you know really
serious suffering and catastrophe and
and one of the things the big you said
is we want to build a series of
compartments our version of what would
be a wall around this loop in lower
Manhattan around this you each chain
you're varying by neighborhood that
would that would keep that scene from
happening so if you've walked around the
Hudson recently on the west side you
know that that white wall doesn't exist
it's kind of like a sculpture of that
concept but it's also actually sea wall
so they said could we could we blow up
the notion of a wall and actually create
a series of water management systems
that would really beautify the
riverfront and not only protect people
from a storm but also make this part of
New York more pleasant to walk on every
day and there's no reason why you know
the west side of Manhattan can't look
like this so that on a day like sandy
instead of the scene with the cars
that's what you got the guys walking is
probably a little bit glib but other
than that it's it's not impossible to do
something like that right and so that
was the West Side and this is the Lower
East Side which had even more
catastrophic flooding and far higher
level of vulnerability and so I live
like right in the center of Greenwich
Village and my NYU's right there and I
started noticing this thing which is has
anyone ever been for a run in New York
City in lower Manhattan there whenever
gone jogging in lower Manhattan okay so
if you've ever jogged in lower Manhattan
not Central Park you you go to the west
side on the Hudson right and the reason
you go to the west side is because this
is this is what happens when you go for
a run on the Lower East Side
it's a kind of run that makes you very
happy to live in San Francisco I have to
pause every few minutes to get water so
I just put those in okay so it's a
really ugly landscape it's a very gray
landscape on the lower east side and
it's a poor area and the the big you
also had a compartment for this area
that involved creating again a
protective layer on the river but now
the the East River looks like this it's
a bridging berm a sloped Park right
where the stairs and the and the green
space are protecting people from water
but also think about that run that we
just took together it would be much
nicer for people to use that river front
if it looked like this all the time and
the idea here is we are about to embark
on this program of spending billions and
ultimately trillions of dollars on
something called climate security and if
you think about Homeland Security as a
political project and an architectural
project you think about urban design in
the age of homeland security think about
the money we spent on homeland security
it gets exponential if you throw in the
wars we're gonna make a comparable kind
of investment in climate security in the
course of the next several decades and
if we just build to wall out the bad
weather we're gonna have a very ugly
environment but we can use this moment
of climate security and building
infrastructure to build things that keep
us safe during a crisis but also make
our lives better every day and that was
a fundamental goal like at the root of
this rebuild by design idea was let's be
attentive to issues of inequality and
let's make sure that when we design
things we're designing things that
aren't just good for keeping us from a
hurricane but also make daily life
better so we get not just the reduced
death rate but also the five years of
life expectancy right we want both of
those things to work and I'll tell you
something that that's kind of a fantasy
but I'd like to put that up there
don't don't expect that so here's a cool
thing about this that big new project
was funded it's gotten
about 700 million dollars of funding so
far
it needs more to do the whole thing but
in my version of the way the world works
if there's two different parts of lower
Manhattan that want the money and one is
on the kind of Greenwich Village Tribeca
side and the others on the Lower East
Side which has this thick concentration
of public housing and Chinatown in the
way that I teach kind of the sociology
of power the west side gets the money
right but because of the political
leaders who happen to be in power when
this was allocated the funds for the
first tranche of money is going to the
east of the Lower East Side where the
vulnerability is where you can actually
address inequality but that's an
arbitrary thing right if you have a
certain president and a certain governor
and a certain mayor and they're aligned
and they think you know when we spend
federal money we need to deal with
inequality right and we need to enhance
the quality of life for people who don't
have it as much of a chance you get a
spending decision like that if you have
a imagine a different political
leadership you could very easily have
the money go to the people who already
have right so mar-a-lago is going to be
safe but these guys won't be last thing
I want to I want to share with you we
the the project gets funded on the Lower
East Side there's these communities that
are there and let's go back to our
inequality theme so we have this
beautiful vision of this Park Slope Park
land that's going to make being on the
Lower East Side feel better all the time
and we built this project through
stakeholder meetings where people
articulate their sense of what they want
right they give us a fantasy for what it
could look like and we work with them
and we and they get it and the money's
there and we're about to do it and we're
going through the approval process and
the leader of the community organization
says okay you're gonna do this now but
can you promise me can you promise me
that when you come in and spend all this
money and it gets beautiful here that
I'm gonna get to stay that my relatives
are gonna get to stay that my community
is going to get to say can you promise
me that when you spend all this money on
the
climate security to make the city look
that beautiful that this isn't just
gonna be the next thing that makes
gentrification happen and I couldn't say
I could promise that and that's another
challenge right dealing with this issue
about equity as we gear up for this new
age of climate so this is relevant to
you for a bunch of reasons you're
American you're vested in New York but
also many of you might not know this the
rebuild by design competition that
started in New York kind of morphed and
became a national competition a few
years ago the HUD brought through with
support of the Rockefeller Foundation
and as of a few months ago it was
publicly announced that the bay area now
has resilient by design competition that
is going to mimic in many ways the
structure of the rebuild by design
competition it's a it's a competition
that's designed to generate to spark
exciting ideas about how to rebuild and
innovate an infrastructure that will
work for the Bay Area in the 21st
century when the new Managing Director
Amanda is sitting in the first row and
she's gonna be running this project so
make sure you come and talk to her
there's one catch about the Bay Area
resilient by design competition that is
that there's not a billion and a half
dollars guaranteed to fund the projects
afterwards so after they come up with
these great design ideas through a
process that's got several million
dollars of funding the cities and the
state are then and the teams are gonna
have to go out and try to find sources
of funding but that will happen because
it's the Bay Area and you guys do things
here
so I talked for probably longer than I
wanted to I noticed a bunch of long now
people trying to throw things at me
while I was up here but I hope you don't
mind me going a little bit long I think
this is the challenge of a lifetime you
know I think this is the challenge of
our moment
and we have a lot of issues on the table
right now there's a lot of you know kind
of issues that feel very urgent in the
country every day you know I don't know
what's going to happen with immigration
I know it's gonna happen to the
Constitution but no matter what this
climate no matter what we say in the
White House no matter how much we fund
scientific organizations we're going to
be living with this challenge and it
might not always feel like it's the most
urgent thing at the moment but our
challenge is at the moment when climate
change feels like the most urgent thing
it will be too late to do anything about
it so people like us who have the luxury
of spending a night in a beautiful bar
in a beautiful city talking about ideas
I think should should take that luxury
and use it as a moment an opportunity to
do something great so thank you very
much
[Music]
Thank You Eric we're gonna we're trying
to get a couple quick questions in Rio's
in the back there with the mic Eric let
me ask you a question we talked about a
couple specific cities more generally
about city cities seem to be both a
point where there could be massive
disasters a concentration of resources
and of people so they are both kind of
more vulnerable to become a giant
disaster but also could prepare and
whatever do you have thoughts kind of
more generally about about what
approaches or other examples you're
seeing of what cities are doing to
prepare we're talking more about the way
things have reacted what do you see are
there trends you see what else can you
say so it really depends on the kind of
city one of the most vulnerable places
on earth is Bangladesh
you know heavily urbanized very dense
population completely vulnerable to
extreme weather events you know
especially you know massive and
immediate flooding and you know some of
the most innovative and life-saving
programs in Bangladesh involve things
like teaching women and children to swim
that's an adaptation strategy providing
basic life skills that people need to
survive situations where in the past
they've been left to fend for themselves
and you know several relief
organizations have managed to work on
this and reduce the mortality by tens of
thousands of people in recent events so
it goes from kind of really like
baseline skill level work you know to
places like Singapore that are so
completely vulnerable to the elements
and are you know these kind of island
nations that are dependent on you know
nations around them where they have no
choice but to become technological
leaders that you know building systems
that are going to withstand you know
massive downpour or they're gonna be
able to produce potable water so I see a
lot of variation I guess it kind of I it
goes without saying but I'll say it here
because you know we're settled that
cities can concentrate vulnerability but
same time is a very strong school of
thought that thinks that you know we
need to be urbanized we need to live in
more denser and more dense settlements
because then we reduce our need for cars
for private automobiles we can walk more
places you know if you live in high-rise
buildings you probably have much less
demand for artificial cooling and
heating and so you know there's a you
know this writer David Owen who says
there's nothing greener than tar and
that's that's probably right in some
ways although I think as we look at this
question more closely we realize you
know if you live in a city like San
Francisco or Manhattan you shouldn't
just pat yourself on the back for being
awesome because you know you have this
incredible you know condo if you can if
you consume and travel the way that
people in places like New York and San
Francisco consume and travel your
individual carbon footprint is probably
very very high compared to other people
on earth so there you go it's a that
Bangladesh example shows that not all
the solutions are capital intensive
sometimes their population intensive and
training right think about the Chicago
example I mean there's there's really
low tech you know relatively inexpensive
things that can keep a place connected
and so you know when I was working with
the teams around sandy and rebuild by
design one of the architecture and
engineering groups had this idea for
building what they called resilient
centers and they wanted to to build like
a new resilience building in every
neighborhood and it would you know be
there in a crisis and it would have a
backup power generator and we'd have all
this programming every day and they had
these really great ambitions for what
this what it would mean to build a
resilient Center and as it happened just
when we did that they're talking about
that we walked by a neighborhood library
and I said there's your resilience
center going to any neighborhood for one
of the great things if you go into any
city there's a neighborhood library in
that city that people of all ages use
all the time for a range of different
things they trust the people who are
there the ethic of the library is come
in we're not going to ask you for ID
you know you have to work so hard to get
kicked out of a library like you really
you have to like devise the most evil
plan to get kicked out of the library
like everybody in a library is there to
help you and and so if instead of
building a brand new resilience center
we said like how could we update our
libraries in cities so that every branch
system you know hat was not just
welcoming all the time was not just a
more pleasant environment but we add
bathrooms because they all need more
bathrooms but also you know they would
have more flexible space that could be
converted into a relief center they
would all have backup power they'd all
have a wireless mesh network so that you
could get internet access when systems
were down like we have some facilities
in place that we could just build up a
little bit more and that doesn't cost a
trillion dollars all right we've got a
question right yes Eric I really
appreciated your talk you are talking
straight forward and I really really
like that but you know we're gonna talk
about the long term problems of climate
change and I'd like to put that in one
context last year we passed 400 parts
per million carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere in my mind the likelihood
that we'll ever see that again would be
maybe in a hundred thousand years
because we are not really addressing the
mitigation that we need to yeah when the
earth was last at 400 parts per million
was about three billion three million
years ago in the machine and sea level
would be about where those lights are
that was be the low part 15 meters 50
feet above sea level up to 85 feet above
sea level
to stop that is likely impossible but we
could maybe make it a little lower if we
work our asses off and really come
together like saul griffith said this is
like world war two but with all the
combatants on the same side yeah
can you comment on that well so i want i
want to make you clear that you are
right that that is the most urgent
problem we face that all of this stuff
is kind of secondary to mitigation so
you can only mitigate so much right so
if we if we get if we get to the point
where we're on the red line and the
slide i showed you before
it's all commentary because we have such
massive changes
to the places that we've settled and to
our systems that uphold us that you know
like we'll all be thanking Elon Musk for
that SpaceX stuff that gets us to
another place it was really exciting to
learn that they just discovered planets
that possibly host life it was like just
in time you know so so so I think that's
I think you're right about mitigation so
I think that we all know what the bad
news is right the good news is that this
conversion to renewables is happening
and it's kind of happening no matter
what we do it's you know we could make
it happen more slowly and we can depress
the market for you know electric cars
and for other renewable sources of
energy wind and solar here and certainly
you know I predict that this
administration we have now will do that
but the trend is turning and it's
getting to the point where the costs of
conversion are relatively low now we're
gonna have to rebuild power grids and
you can't do that if you don't have
major federal investment and so at some
point something something has to happen
that I can't quite anticipate but there
is a part of me that you know doesn't
think we're quite that stupid that that
thinks that it's it's going to happen
and the question is just you know when
and so so what I what I did in my own
work as I said all right this is going
to be the thing that I own you know like
I don't own the problem but this will be
my this will make this my life's work
right now so I will work on this issue
and what the climate scientists I know
say is look we're out there on our own
at this point you know we had so many
tough questions thirty years ago and
we've just spent all this time fighting
really brutal political battles trying
to establish the basic science about
what's happening in our environment and
now we have all these puzzles that are
social and behavioral and we need your
help so we use social scientists kind of
come up to the plate and so the reason
you know the thing I'm doing at the
Center for Advanced Study at Stanford
this year is trying to work with
Stanford to build a program that will
really kind of bring more social
scientists into the world of
this climate change debate it's a hard
thing to do because of the you know kind
of historic hierarchies of the
disciplines where like I said in the
beginning the environmental stuff is
marginalized and the high status stuff
is dealing with other problems but we're
trying to say you know it's time for us
to join the world so that's our modest
way of helping and and you're working on
a book about social infrastructure we're
gonna book that's about what I called
social infrastructure which you know
hits on many of the themes from tonight
but explore some other ones as well
what's the timeline
are you beginning of ever ask that to an
author you host the whole damn series
and you ask questions we're long-term
thinkers we always say it's not done yet
okay okay I'm working hard man all right
you took a night off yeah um I have a
question just on a slightly more modular
version of the you know there's there's
one mode of thought where you build the
wall around all of lower Manhattan
there's also one where you build into
building codes that they have to be
flood resistant there's you know I live
in I moved into a building in Sausalito
about ten years ago and we were putting
a machine shop into the first floor
right on the water and the very first
thing we did was put in flood gates and
we've had to raise them probably 15
times in ten years and they've kept the
water out and so that was vastly cheaper
than even paying the insurance premiums
have they been flooded yeah but in the
United States we generally kind of work
on this mode of we wait for the flood to
happen then we insure it but then the
insurance company's got a business
because they all get insured instead of
paying you know a few thousand dollars
on the front end but you know we did do
things like the AEA which cost you know
at least on the order of magnitude as it
would cost to kind of flood proof most
buildings so I'm just wondering if
you've seen any efforts that are on this
more modular effort where you just say
you know like the earthquake retrofits
that happen here in San Francisco or
something like that Kay yes absolutely
and this is a very important point but
two issues first issue is
we have a you know a lot of these areas
that are most vulnerable are very
heavily built up already right and
there's a lot of subsurface
infrastructure that's hard to elevate
and protect so the price tag for keeping
the subway system dry in New York City
is incredibly high and the price tag for
updating the power grid is incredibly
high and if you think about all those
high-rises that are completely
vulnerable
you know in San Francisco and Manhattan
and you know you name your city it's
it's it's not as easy an update if you
know as it is here so so it's it's it is
challenging to do it but let me so
here's that here's another political
leadership thing so what another thing
that President Obama did not long before
about a year before he left office he
said you know another rule that you
could not get federal funds for any kind
of rebuilding project you know whether
it's a house or a piece of
infrastructure if you didn't have an
estimate for sea level rise that would
tune you to the kinds of vulnerabilities
in the place where the structure is and
you'd have to you know build to code in
anticipation of you know sea level rise
Forex time horizon and that had very
very high stakes decision for the way
that federal money went especially for
these larger infrastructure projects
right so now we're in this really
interesting situation we have a
president who says you know he's gonna
find a trillion dollars to spend on
infrastructure maybe it's gonna be 500
billion I don't know what it's going to
be it could be public money it could be
private money but if the policy on
climate is to say climate change is not
real you know it's a theory he might
also say then we don't have to take
those things into consideration in which
case we might start building very
expensive infrastructure without taking
sea level rise into account so back to
the long consideration what when you
read a story about an
your project that the United States is
taking on the highway tunnel bridge
transits think about the New York City
subway system or the water system in San
Francisco you know and think about how
long we want our infrastructure to last
and if we start to build those
structures if we cite those structures
if we compose those structures design
those structures without taking into
consideration a trend in the climate
that we know is happening we're gonna
we're gonna just burn that money we're
just gonna burn the money the way they
burnt their money in New York with that
subway so it's totally an apt question
maybe I mean what's at stake in this
fight between Prewitt and the state of
California is Pruitt saying you know you
know this is on emission standards but
you know that it's true it seems to be
saying that he wants to challenge the
State of California's right to have its
own standards for emissions which were
there because they were grandfathered in
right Pruitt has indicated that he wants
to make it have a legal fight against
the state of California so that
California can't have its own standards
so I don't know where that's gonna play
out and you know one of my jobs and I
think one of the jobs of anyone who's
really concerned about this issue is to
have a sociologist so I have not cracked
this problem like how do you make issues
like this feel alive and urgent and
relevant so that we can talk about them
in politics in the same way that we talk
about Trump's tweets you know it's
really a hard thing I mean this I I like
I've invite and plead with you to it
helped us think about how to deal with
this so it's such a hard problem for
people to get their minds around you
know it is so hard to convey urgency and
drama and significance right so we have
these disasters as resources because
like so say so Chicago had this heatwave
and
700-plus people died but it wasn't
spectacular it didn't make for good
television
who cares about Chicago and it didn't
you know so did tows a non-event
so then you have this spectacular storm
that hits New York City that scares
Washington DC that scares Boston a great
hits the power corridor of New York far
fewer people die but there's tens of
billions of dollars in damage and an
incredible television and you know now
every government official and
philanthropic leader and business owner
in the region is suddenly attuned to
climate change and so like there were
years after that when my Institute like
I wish I was still in this moment but we
couldn't take any more money because
everybody wanted to do stuff and there
just weren't enough organizations that
were doing this work and now I fear that
we're kind of forgotten about that and I
get how urgent all the other stuff is
I'm not saying like don't worry about
this whole immigration thing it's gonna
be fine
I don't feel that way at all but I don't
want us to forget about this all right
we're gonna have to leave it there but
Eric you're gonna stick around sure yeah
a reminder we have copies of Eric's book
he's gonna be signing the book he's
gonna be happy to take more of your
questions continue this discussion
things about states rights and the
different different cover ability of
different types of disasters so please
stick around and thank you again so much
for coming out tonight this is along now
challenge coins a little token of our
thanks for for speaking one more time
around of applause for Eric and thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]